earlier this year Mark Wahlberg's
passion project father Stu a Redemptive
tale of a roustabout who finds God and
ends up saving his family in the process
it made a huge splash of the box office
well now in an unorthodox move Sony is
bringing the movie back to theaters at
the top of December in a new form they
call it father Stu reborn joining me to
discuss is the film star and producer
Mark Wahlberg Mark thanks for being with
us for taking a little time from your
Thanksgiving Eve now this is an odd move
Mark to release a movie in the same year
it was originally released why did you
in the studio decide to do it this way
well given the nature of the the R rated
movie uh lots of families didn't feel
comfortable uh with their children
seeing it but they really wanted them to
get the message so
um because the Archbishop of Archbishop
Thomas of Nevada who had actually
ordained father Stu and Helena Montana
came to me and said Mark I really
understand why the language is there but
it would be ascending to shame for young
people not to see this movie and to
really understand the importance of this
story so we wanted to make sure that we
could share that with children of all
ages and so we recut the film we took
out all 200 and some odd swears and the
film is still as powerful and is
impactful but to see Stu's journey and
the struggle that he went through to
find his calling we felt was really
important for people of all ages to see
well that's what I was going to ask you
Rosalind Ross who was your director here
she told me she cut out about 200
experts it took her a couple of weeks uh
it is it not like a 20-minute movie is
this double time storm Mark what do you
lose in the process or gain you really
didn't lose anything I think especially
for young people they will definitely be
impacted by especially by Stu's
conviction and seeing the story and the
struggle and how he handled uh adversity
and and struggling and suffering the way
that he didn't really embraced it and
found his calling to serve God but I
remember seeing hard times in the
theater with my dad when I was seven or
eight years old had a profound effect
impact on me and it didn't have any bad
language it did have bare knuckle boxing
but I think then it will allow children
to then go and see the movie in the way
that it was originally intended when
they get a little bit older and it's
more age-appropriate for them why do you
think it's important for kids and
families particularly boys to see this
movie now Mark I know that was a goal
for you that that young boy should see
this with their dads
yeah I really wanted young people uh as
a whole to see but especially young boys
because I think it really you really
kind of hopefully can avoid making a lot
of the mistakes that Stu made and going
through a lot of the struggles that he
did uh I think you know it's it's a
brutally honest depiction of somebody
who's struggling trying to find their
own way trying to find their calling and
kind of going through the hardships
especially living life
um and expressing anger in a way that is
not really productive I think Stu uh if
he had a chance at like all of us to go
back and do it differently we would but
we want to prevent kids from making a
lot of the same mistakes that we made it
certainly mistakes that I made so
anything that we can do to kind of show
them an easier path to uh to serving God
and just being positive productive
members of society in the community and
especially in the church and and
gravitating towards their faith whether
that's Catholicism or Judaism or or
Islam or or Buddhism or or any other
form of Faith mark father Stuart long
was an actual person this is based on a
real life story one that I hadn't heard
before you showed me this film the first
time you said this is one of the most
important movies of your career why I
mean I know you obviously put your money
where your mouth is you funded it
yourself
yeah but I you know I I've always
gravitated towards the true stories and
I've made quite a few of them and I feel
like they've always had the most impact
on on people and audiences but this film
especially has touched so many people
and it's reminded them about what life
is really all about and we all deal with
hardships we all deal with loss uh and
and the inevitable but how you cope with
those things and how we're treating and
interacting with one another and
especially in this day and age when
there's so much divide this is a movie
that really brings people together we
want to love and support people we want
people to know that they're not
forgotten we've all made mistakes and
that nobody is beyond Redemption and
again we want to spread a lot more love
and a lot more acceptance well Mark what
I love about it is you have a family
that shattered at the beginning and the
the story really is no family is ever
irredeemable no peace can't be put back
together and sometimes on the far side
of suffering that's where you find
Redemption and that's a hard path but
it's a true path now Mark you have a new
focus it seems to me not only on family
in in the film projects you're embracing
but your your own family you decided to
move to Nevada recently to give them a
fresh start why what was happening in LA
uh well we had one child who was you
know
um kind of being I would she's she's on
an amazing place now so I don't want to
put her or her business out there but
you know it was a challenge there's a
challenge growing up uh with a celebrity
name it's a challenge growing up under
the spotlight and we just wanted to give
our chance uh kids the best chance to be
successful and they've been thriving in
a new environment
um you know there's a lot of pressure
being attached to to me and and that
sort of thing I just wanted them to have
their own space in their own place and
they've been doing amazing
um you know it is possible to raise uh
healthy happy children anywhere and it's
also uh no real safe place to avoid
drugs and peer pressure and all of those
things that come along with being a
young impressionable child but I think
in this particular safe environment it
was the best thing for my children and
uh and hopefully I can also do lots of
great things as far as creating jobs and
opportunity there as well so there was
just so many Pros to to moving there and
giving us all a fresh start yeah well I
love that and your wife I know stays
close to them when you're working and
that too is such an important foundation
in the family I mean it's it's great so
like Angela Lansbury she she is the
anchor yeah my my wife is the anger she
is the foundation she is the glue she is
the reason why my kids are thriving I
yeah I really have to and I don't give
her enough credit as often as it's
deserved but uh she is she is the one
who gets all the credit and it's well
deserved I have the same story pal my
Rebecca is does the same thing at home
what are you most thankful for this
Thanksgiving Mark Before I Let You Go oh
you know uh Thanksgiving obviously is my
my favorite holiday I'm just grateful
um that I have my health that I uh I'm
so blessed and so fortunate and you know
that now my my focus has has has shifted
to things that are going to hopefully
make a more positive impact on people
and help people and bring people
together
um you know that I was able to make my
parents proud before they passed I have
so many reasons to be grateful I really
do I wear out the you know the cloth on
my on my pajamas every morning
expressing my gratitude you know and I
will continue to do that and and
hopefully that will rub off on my
children and other people that I'm
around that I continue to express that
and that I have to do that on a daily
basis well we're thankful to you uh you
brought a great uh Beacon of Hope I
think for a lot of people through this
film this year
um and uh before I I sign off there were
reports I read that you're being
approached to join the Marvel Universe
are you getting fitted for your spandex
before I let you go
no there is no truth to that I've never
been approached to ask and I don't know
if I would ever have the courage to walk
out of my trailer in one of those
costumes but that being said I am
focusing on and I'm looking forward to
working with you and other folks in the
faith-based space and creating other
opportunities to tell wonderful stories
that will bring people closer together
all right and bring people closer to God
that's a great goal in the New Year I'll
leave it there Happy Thanksgiving to you
and your family and I want to encourage
everybody uh father Stu reborn hits
theaters everywhere December 9th it's
worth seeing and bring your family with
you Happy Thanksgiving Mark to you and
all the wahlbergs God bless you thank
you likewise hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else